in type en indonésie comme chez au
vietnam jaba en chine comme colonne au
perron s'il vous est déjà arrivé que
votre reee adhère écart est mêlé au fond
de votre casserole sans le savoir vous
avez créé le début de ces plats
en corée c'est le nour une j ai en iran
on l'était dit c'est quelque chose que
tout le monde adore adore c'est dans le
fond c'est pas un plat le tabligh c'est
le résultat de la cuisson du riz etc le
croustillant dans le fond de la
casserole
et reid m'a sonné a grandi dans un
quartier multiethnique de montréal
passionné de culture perse elle a ouvert
son restaurant en s'inspirant entre
autres de la cuisine de l'iran
j'ai connu la bof iranienne depuis que
j'étais tout petit et j'ai adoré et
après ça fait 13 ans maintenant que j'ai
rencontré mon job qui est iranien
des ingrédients simples composent le
tagging du riz basmati du sel du beurre
clarifié de l'huile et de l'eau parfumée
au safran
[Musique]
après avoir bien rincer le riz ont fait
une première cuisson d'environ trois
minutes pour l'attendrir puis c'est
parti pour la préparation du tabligh
bref ça devient un peu chaud que
possible mais rajouter quelques pour le
goût et la couleur erwin ajoute avec
prudence de l'eau parfumée ou s'apprend
d'élus moment pour commencer à rajouter
notre
une première couche de riz pour couvrir
le fond de la casserole ensuite on
ajoute le reste en formant une pyramide
et on le connaît on les sarries quelques
minutes sur le maximum là ça va prendre
à peu près quatre minutes comme ça qu'on
commence si jamais on n'est pas ce qu'on
a mis à ces pays ont prêté leurs
capitaux on veut être contenu à cuirieux
riz à la vapeur
donc j'étais petit trou et je mange tout
doucement verser le mélange d'eau chaude
et de vol qualifié ça va et plus ça va
paraître plus de vapeur et le beurre va
faire un don vous en faites
après quelques minutes est vrai de la
joute linge de table afin que la vapeur
soit absorbée pour ne pas retomber dans
laurie
il le reste de la cuisson ça va être fou
le plus bas par la regarde ces nouveaux
jets au fonds de casseroles
à la manière coréenne maintenant pour
jade ses eaux du restaurant sam le
nouveau round j n'a plus de secret
est tous les rapports où trouver le
doury christien écrit au fonds de
casseroles et on doit trouver la façon
pour manger ça
on retrouve le neurone j dans le fond de
la casserole ayant servi à cuire le riz
par la suite les coréens ont l'habitude
de faire une diffusion à partir de cette
croûte en y versant de l'eau
c'est comme de thé chinois bois de thé
après repas mais coréenne on boit le no
logic le sud de neurologie comme adultes
et on peut facilement faire d'une rue ji
à la maison ses doigts ap le manx pour
faire bouger
j'ai mis un peu raté vraiment minimum ça
prendra cinq minutes après vous pour
tourner ses limites au tracé mais ne
savait trouver bon nouveau c'est après
comme pour l'état digues et rania cette
croûte de riz s'utilise de plusieurs
façons en accompagnement
ça c'est le sauter s'effrite maire
sortait aux légumes et il faut au fond 2
case zéro il ya lenovo chine
le plat le plus populaire chez les
coréens et le bim bam une fois le riz
est allé au fond de la poêle de pierre
tous les ingrédients sont ajoutés pour
ensuite laisser cuire sur le feu de
cette façon le neurone j se formera au
fond c'est vraiment le meilleur lemay
parts de be bop après manger granit et
le duriez au fond c'est beau
de retour chez eux et run après environ
60 minutes de cuisson
c'est l'heure de vérité
que c'est beau voilà le têt digue laisse
voir sa belle couleur car émises et
est-ce que ça ressemble vous avez manqué
de le faire me tadic pour laquelle on se
battait quand on était jeune c'était
trop qui peut s'asseoir ou me rendre
autour de la table pour peut-être avoir
une chance d'être passé débat est là
vous nous le servez avec quoi qu'est-ce
que vous avez assez et un plat
traditionnel qui s'appelle le fsn jones
et un braisé qui vient du nom de
l'erreur c'est comme grenade et
noix de grenoble avec des petites
boulettes d'agneau
[Musique]
c'est vraiment très bon et cette texture
loi est unique pour nous c'est vraiment
le summum de
supporters c'est christian hot rod et
borie ben merci de nous faire voyager
comme ça c'est ta gueule lésés
c'est